all companies that have lost
65% of their turnover I remind you that
previously it was 80% so we
have lowered the threshold 65% loss
of turnover will be eligible for
reimbursement of partial activity at
100%  without remaining payable, all
companies that are subject to
health restriction measures will
also have access to this compensation for
100% of partial activity, for
example a bar which no longer has the right
today to serve its customers from
mud which will therefore experience a
health restriction measure will have access to
partial activity reimbursed at 100%
without remaining charge I simply wanted
to start this year 2022 by noting
that as since the start of the crisis
we have been alongside companies in
difficulty we are alongside
employees in difficulty our method of
managing the crisis has enabled us to
revive economic activity very quickly
and very strongly to have a level
of growth codes  very high economic nce in
2021 to find before italy
before germany before spain our level
of economic activity before the crisis to
find a good level of employment so this
is proof that it is the right one
method when the method is good it
should not be changed